a safe return to work with the help of
edge computing
the all-new ibm cloud security and
compliance center
in the introduction of ibm cloud
databases from mongodb enterprise
all on this episode of ibm cloudnow
what's up everyone my name is ian and
i'm back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements
from ibm cloud i want to start the show
by talking about a really cool way
that edge computing is being used to
help businesses reopen
and operate safely we know face masks
can substantially reduce the
transmission of aerosol-borne viruses
but sometimes people forget to wear them
properly or at all
ibm edge application manager places
analytical workloads with edge-enabled
cameras that can recognize face masks
and determine if they're being worn
effectively since analysis is performed
at the camera
the video data and individual privacy
are protected
you also avoid the expense of
transmitting storing or analyzing that
image data any further
alerts are sent every time the camera
detects an improperly worn or
non-existent face mask
then it sends the aggregated data back
to the ibm maximo
worker insights platform allowing you to
highlight face mask activity
in your facilities it's pretty amazing
stuff right
and that's only scratching the surface
if you check out the blogs in the
description you'll also find out how ibm
edge application manager
is using edge computing to monitor crowd
density
social distancing and elevated body
temps of those who are entering an
establishment
so click the links below to learn more
and make sure you're wearing your mask
right
next up as enterprises move regulated
workloads to public cloud
we believe that is essential to
establish successful cultures of
continuous cloud security and compliance
and that's why we're really proud to
introduce the ibm cloud security and
compliance center in collaboration with
ibm research
it's a solution that is built directly
into the cloud platform and ready to use
the security and compliance center
allows you to build checks into everyday
workloads
and it is comprised of the
simplification of three different
capabilities
security and compliance posture
management configuration governance
and security insights it's really easy
to get started and if you click on the
blog linked in the description
you'll be able to follow a tutorial that
will get you rolling with a security and
compliance center
finally i want to close out this episode
by introducing ibm cloud databases for
mongodb enterprise
now customers can tap into the full
power of mongodb for enterprise
applications
especially those in regulated
environments that need powerful data
encryption capabilities
and auditability our partnership with
mongodb
allows you to leverage the latest
mongodb features in authentic apis
while taking advantage of full
automation of some of the more
common painstaking database
administration tasks
databases for mongodb enterprise goes
above and beyond the standard plan by
offering a bunch of features
for security performance and
auditability
this includes access to mongodb metrics
performance advisor
and data explorer through our ops
manager portal an auditing capability
for your mongodb instances
and fips algorithms and automatic
client-side encryption
to learn more about databases for
mongodb enterprise see the link i've got
below
thanks for joining me today for this
episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered
make sure you explore the links in the
description of this video and again
please don't forget to subscribe to our
channel to stay up to date on what's
going on in the cloud
now